khloe kardashian shuts down trolls who
says she's not as important as her
sisters kim and courtney
you just have to
deal with it here's what happened
chloe's pal stassi shared this glam
snapshot posing alongside chloe and her
sis kim at vanity fair's oscar party on
sunday
we all want to be cute over here okay
that's when an instagram user took the
opportunity to throw some shade clo's
way commenting wait so chloe was there
but not important enough to walk the red
carpet and then to add insult to injury
she is the only kardashian not in the
met gala yeah it's true khloe skipped
out on walking the carpet while her
siblings came in court plus kendall
jenner chose the pose for the paparazzi
and she's never attended the met gala
alongside her famous fam who all show up
year after year isn't that crazy
but koko handled the unsolicited
feedback like a boss firing back with
this comeback quote i don't know what on
earth you're talking about and where you
think you come up with these stories
that you assume are facts both of your
comments are untrue babe it is what it
is at this point chloe is the clapback
queen she's got a long history of
defending herself in the comments
section in january after the reality
star shared this pic her seemingly
distorted fingers inspired some fans to
pull out the phrase chicken feet hands
under her post
now she didn't reply directly to that
criticism but fans thought she did when
she posted this promo shot for her brand
see how her hands are covered up well
one commenter caught her out for masking
her mitts after all the mean messages
about that original pig but chloe hit
right back telling the fan quote lol
never my hands are beautiful baby i
don't take it too seriously because
god only knows if i looked at their
photos what they look like and in real
life
and when she's not coming for her haters
in the comments chloe's blessing us with
lots of cuteness on her feed thanks in
large part to her daughter true
let's go girls
that's the three-year-old singing the
encanto earworm we don't talk about
bruno with her cousin dream daughter of
chloe's brother rob
[Music]
[Music]
you